welcome again to the nazca 2011 winter
webinar series we hope that you found
these webinars to be interesting and
informative this webinar is the last one
in the series for 2011 our speakers
today are dr. James lamantia who's going
to be talking about nematodes and root
rots and dr. Richard calls will be
discussing advances in weevil management
both are from the connect a Greek ulch
Earl experiment station just a few
housekeeping things before we start if
you're interested in viewing the
recorded webinars if you look in the web
links box over here you'll see webinar
archive if you click on that you'll see
a URL appears in the browse to box just
click on that and it will open in a
window behind this window and all of the
recorded webinars will be there for you
to access later the other thing is we're
interested in having some feedback from
you about the series and so we have a
short five question online survey this
will help us determine the effectiveness
of this type of program what you liked
about it what you may not have liked
about it and then possible topics of
interest for a future series hosted by
Nazca and if you click on again in the
web link box on the exit survey you'll
find the URL there and you can just
browse there and it should take you
maybe five minutes at the most to
complete the survey for us in terms of
Nazca and their hosting of the winter
webinar series we wish to thank you very
much Nazca for hosting the series and
there are some membership information
for you that we hope you'll look through
why would you consider joining an
association like Nazca what what are the
membership benefits to that and then a
membership application blank and those
are in the file share box in the bottom
right side of your screen we did have
some people registering even today for
this last webinar and so I'll just give
a brief reminder of the options that you
have if
are interested in in commenting or
asking a question in the bottom of the
screen you'll see what's called the chat
box and you can type in that long white
box and then either hit the little
dialogue icon or hit enter and it will
be posted to everyone who's
participating up on the top of your
screen you see a little icon of a person
with their hand raised several options
under that drop-down menu you could
agree or disagree with a comment that
the speaker is making you can ask them
to speak louder or softer to slow up or
go faster if they say something funny
you can pick the smiley face for
laughter and clapping hands for applause
all right I believe we're ready to begin
our first speaker today is dr. James
lamantia Jim is a plant pathologist
nematology and the chief scientist at
the connecticut Agricultural Experiment
Station Valley laboratory in Windsor
Connecticut Jim earned his BS in biology
from Fitchburg State College in
Massachusetts and ms and PhD degrees in
plant pinol plant pathology from Cornell
University his research interests are
biology and control of plant diseases
caused by nematodes and fungi areas of
emphasis include non-chemical controls
such as plant resistance and cropping
systems jim has 25 years of experience
researching strawberry diseases we're
very fortunate to have a gym with us
today
Jim hi good afternoon everybody can you
hear me Kathy yes okay and we'll get
started so what I'm going to talk about
are these nematodes and root rots that
occur on strawberries often strawberry
root diseases whether they're nematodes
or fungi or anything else that we sort
of come at this because the plants are
doing poorly or they're dying and we
really don't see anything visible on the
foliage so what we need to find out is
what are the problems and then how do we
deal with them so what I'm going to do
is talk about some of these root rots
and then talk about nematodes and then
talk about black root rot where it's a
combination of nematodes in and fungi
and just then how we can try to deal
with some of these things most common
ones are probably red steel pythium and
black root rot and I'll go through those
sort of in order here in addition we
have lesion nematodes and root-knot
nematodes is the root not on
strawberries particularly in the
Northeast and in Canada temperate areas
or maleta kind appli and I'll talk about
that as well and then because disease
really doesn't occur on its own in a
vacuum we have to consider the
environmental effects of this the
stresses to the plants that can increase
disease such as compaction too much or
too little water stressful ph's and then
nutrient too much or too little and
again that all kind of comes into this
disease triangle whenever a plant
pathologist gives a talk right we're
required to give to show the slide I
think we have to have a susceptible
plant rather than a resistant type a
causal agent which is the pathogen that
we're trying to deal with and it may be
multiple disease always doesn't occur on
a you know pure cultures and then the
environment that the plant and the
pathogen are interacting in so go to the
first disease red steel the symptoms of
this and the symptoms of most of these
root diseases as I said before just sort
of poor vigor the tops are dying back
stunting the plants are under stress and
having problems and diagnosis is a
thing we need to do so under cool
conditions when you when you dig these
plants up and look at them you can find
red vascular tissue which is where the
common name red steel comes from you
don't always see this and if it's late a
little later in the summer about harvest
time as its warming often that symptom
disappears and you just see a sort of a
rat tail root rot symptom and that the
pathogen is persistent in the soil for
years now under the right conditions you
can see the this reddish vascular tissue
and just sort of peel this back with
your thumbnail or sometimes with a knife
and you can notice that the cortex here
is nice and white the vascular tissues
where the disease is occurring and it's
and it's dying now and the in the bottom
left here you can see this Oh sport and
this is the reason why this pathogen can
be persistent in the soil for years and
years even in the absence of a host
these are thick walled resting spores
this is a water mold that produces these
all sports it's a sexually produced
spore and they can persist under tough
conditions for a long period of time so
once its present in the field you can
count on it almost always being there
now water mols produce multiple kinds of
spores they produce those resting spores
that's the long-term type of spore they
also produce sporangia which can act as
a let me show you right here in the
middle this is this brand you hear this
is sort of a lemon shaped spore that can
act at almost like a seed you can
germinate directly under under
conditions where its water is there's a
excess of water the soil pores are
flooded they often read if ur n she ate
and produce those spores and you can see
that I have the little black arrows here
as well pointing it so those pores and
if you look at the use your imagination
here you can imagine that there are
multiples though lots of results for
swimming around in this now these
actually have flagella and they can swim
and they chemically are attracted to
strawberry roots so that you can imagine
under under wet conditions flooded
conditions
of a single spring gym that's
germinating and causing disease you get
a little cluster bomb effect where now
you've got 20 to 40 those spores that
come out of this and then swim through
the flooded sale pores attracted to the
strawberry Bruce so that's one of the
reasons why flooded conditions are so
damaging for for this particular disease
as I said it's a water mold severe under
wet conditions so some of the things we
can do about this are to improve
drainage grow plants on raised beds tile
fields do whatever needs to be done
avoid compaction and plow pans which can
also increase flooding in the root zone
resistant cultivars there are a number
of different cultivars I've listed a few
here if you go to the Cornell
information there's a lot of different
places we can look at different
varieties and varieties will have some
level resistance to phytophthora for
Gary in addition some of the fungicides
may help reduce disease in combination
with resistance or environmental changes
it's difficult to rely only on
fungicides alone some of the fungicides
are aliette type riddim ill and then the
phosphorous acid phosphate
another water mold that can attack the
roots is the Pythian root rot this is
one that occurs a lot of different
places a lot of different species
probably that even attack strawberries
it's common in vegetables it's common in
in many soils all over all over the
North America and what you can see here
are these large numbers of these old
sports again in the roots now the
symptoms of pythium root rot are sort of
a watery rot of the of the route they
tend not to be as dramatic as the
phytophthora part of me as the proper
for gary or even as a black route right
which we'll talk about in a little bit
they tend to be more root nibblers they
take out the fine feeder roots and again
under cool wet conditions stressed
plants so some of the same management
tactics that you can use for fight after
for Gary also apply to pythium improving
drainage reducing compaction growing on
beds that sort of thing and then some of
the same fungicides may be helpful now
a little bit about some of the nematodes
some of these and Emma totems on
strawberries I think are often under
recognized the northern route not
nematode milega appli is more common I
think then people realize it causes
galls on roots but these Gauls sometimes
are fairly short-lived you can see here
these are actually clusters of multiple
calls if this area here has probably
five or six different calls there's an
area here if you look at this larger
area from in this sort of quadrant here
there's probably 25 galls in this
cluster of the route they also cause
routes to be the branch more commonly
than they would normally do and so we
get these hairy root symptoms now the
Gauls for northern route not nematode
are much smaller than those that you see
in the books for the southern route knot
nematodes you see the large galls and
you know pictures on tomatoes at all
these tend to be fairly small and
because strawberry roots can be a little
woodier they're even smaller on
strawberry not as obvious as they are on
some other crops now Emma toads are
plant parasitic roundworms there's
number of different kinds of northern
route and I nematode is one that is
called an endoparasites sedentary endo
parasite they are there are eggs see
here that that develop at the pointer
out it developed into juveniles that
juveniles go into the group they cause
the route to establish feeding cells
which actives transfer so so that
they're the same kind of cells that pump
nutrients into fruit except in this case
they're taking the nutrients and giving
it to the nematode upon which you know
it feeds and as a result they increase
in size fairly dramatically this would
be a juvenile here and they increase in
size to these large females which are
essentially egg-laying machines they go
through several moles and then the
females produce an egg mass that's about
the same size as the female so they're
very feet kind they tend to infect hit
the root tips so you can see multiple
juvenile stained red here in the root
tip on the inset then the root tip
itself tends to stop growing gets
swollen and as a result of that you
often get
branching so you get these little areas
where you get Vera stems being produced
in branch and coming out hence the hairy
root symptom over time as the root
continues to continues to grow you can
get multiple females being produced it
from that which was once was the root
tip so you have the female actually
inside the root here another one over
here and then two more on this side now
this area is the egg mass that's being
produced so when you look again at the
inset here you have this white creamy
colored female this is the head end down
here at the very top and then underneath
is the egg mass again this is a several
hundred eggs which you think about this
she's producing more eggs than than her
own body mass so I mentioned happeh
tends to be more common than we realize
it infects a lot of agronomic crops
almost all vegetables small fruit things
like soybean clover a lot of broadleaf
weeds some of the more common ones of
the purslane plantain dandelion you can
read here however all grain crops are
non host from Oregon happeh so that
gives us an idea of what we can do for
rotation possibility there is two to
rotate with a grain crop now one of the
things when we try to get rid of of
these nematodes with grain crops is it's
often difficult to get all the
strawberry crowns out of the field or
the broadleaf weeds and if those hosts
of the nematode continue to survive in
the field they will be a source of
inoculum and again these nematodes
increase so quickly because they produce
so many eggs that it can be difficult if
you don't get these out to control by
rotation and then finally fumigation but
that's getting to be tougher and tougher
to do as more regulations come in and
make it harder to fumigate lesion
nematode is very common it's probably
the most common nematode in the
northeastern Canada Prada Lanka's
penetrance ism one we see the most this
is a a verme reform nematode it so it's
a migratory indo para cited
does not produce the feem the large
females like the root not does these go
into the roots migrate through the
cortex and cause lesions like you can
see here now this happens to be a
soybean root and you can see these
chocolate brown lesions where the
nematode has moved through soybean is
actually a pretty good indicator of
nematode infection in the field and we
can use this for a bioassay an effect
worked at the Georgia ballet at Cornell
was done is using a using these as a way
for growers to evaluate the level of
lesion nematodes in their field and that
may be something we can talk about in
the future sometime now these nematodes
also go inside the route they migrate
through the cortex and you can see the
the juveniles and the adults stained red
here you can also see the eggs that they
lay as they move along they don't
produce egg masses they just lay them as
they go in the roots or in the soil and
as they move they cause damage they're
feeding on the cell contents and moving
through the cells these nematodes as I
mentioned are very common in our area
they can attack almost almost every
plane you can think of ins in many
respects over 550 species of agronomic
crops and weeds and there's probably
more that we haven't looked at yet now
the grain crops that you're growing for
control mode again appli are almost all
hosts or I don't like its penetrance so
if you're you do need to know what the
nematode problem is before you try to
control it by rotation so we want to
talk a little bit about what these
nematodes do in terms of other than
direct damage they are involved in
another root rot disease called black
root rot this is one that has a complex
cause multiple organisms for us the most
common one is the fungal problem that
causes the root riders is by nucleate
rhizoctonia rhizoctonia for gary very
common in strawberries its associated
with a secure part me a cortical root
rot I'll show you some pictures of that
in a second here and then the lesion
nematodes and stress also increased
disease now again the symptoms of this
are pretty
on the script and hence the common name
the plants are dying they decline over
time the longer you have a field in
production and strawberries the more
likely it is to be a problem with a
black root rot
be clicking to hear at a time and when
you dig these plants up you can see the
plant on the left has this has root rot
you'll see you know black roots actually
fewer roots as well compared to the
healthy plant on the right or healthier
plant on the right so when you look at
those look more closely at those at
those roots you can see that there's a
cortical root rot so the pathogen is
causing the the cortex to die and if you
slice that open you can differentiate
between this and a disease like red
steel because now the the cortex is
dying and turning black and rotting
coming just away sometimes again with a
similar rat tail pipe of symptom but
when you look at the vascular tissue it
remains white for a period of time now
eventually that's all going to die in
the in the plant just the roots just rot
away and disappear turn mushy as I
mentioned the pathogen that causes the
root rot symptom is this rhizoctonia for
Gary very similar to the rise akhon
vegetables but again to buy nucleate
rather than multinucleate and there are
different anastomosis groups and you see
I have a chart here of what what happens
when we come we did experiments in
growth chambers looking at different
isolates of the pathogenic fungus
rhizoctonia and the year anastomosis
groups AG and I these tend to differ a
little bit and they're pathogenicity and
how they do at certain temperatures and
you can see there's no no scale here but
there's the three boxes across the front
are where we have just the right sock
Tony alone with no nematodes the zero
here or with a low level and this is
under these conditions we're getting
twenty-five thirty forty percent root
rot or a higher level on these are what
we would consider to be damaging levels
of lesion nematodes that kindly see
mostly in the populations that we would
see in the field that are causing
stunting so you're right goes from
thirty to thirty-five percent here to
about seventy to eighty percent when we
add the police
nematodes as well so they do interact
and increase the amount of disease
caused by the right effect onium so what
are the effects that we're seeing we did
other experiments here again no
pathogens none the rise like Tony are
for Gary alone or the rhizoctonia plus
Prada Lanka's penetrance the pp you can
see again blackroot right increases even
ten percent with none there probably is
some rhizoctonia and the nuns it's
sometimes difficult to get strawberries
with absolutely no resurrect Tony for
Gary but where we have the pathogen
where we have inoculated we get 22% root
rot more than double it when we have the
resurrect onia in combination with the
the nematode now in addition to visible
disease that we're seeing on the roots
we see reduced length both in structural
roots and in feeder roots so the roots
that are rotting tend to disappear and
we have a smaller root system and over
time it's smaller root system not not so
healthy root system results in a decline
in this this is a lack of vigor and and
debilitating decline in the strawberries
over over time now to talk about the
route route I think we also need to talk
about what route types we're talking
about with strawberry here I'm going to
talk about structural routes these have
both primary and secondary tissues with
a well-developed cortex the structural
roots are the roots that you get when
the larger roots that you get with it
with a transplant those the ones that
are going into the ground we also have
perennial groups healthy plants that are
a couple of years old have very woody
roots these are primarily there's mostly
secondary tissues these are woody
tissues there is no real cortex it's
gone it's been slept off and they have
feeder roots and come off these so both
structure groups and Prairie roots have
these soft primary tissue by primary I
mean non-woody tissues that are thus
feeder roots and these are pretty
short-lived and in the literature they
talk about some of the feeder roots
cycling through about every
two weeks or so which seems very quickly
having trouble here moving one at a time
but these are the structure roots you
can see that they are these white
tissues here and they also have the
feeder roots coming off them
we do a cross section of this you can
see that we have a route with the
vascular tissue I root cortex and then
the epidermis on the outside so this is
the cross section of the of the feeder
roots apartment these structural roots
now those structure votes over time
produce the secondary woody tissue so we
have vascular tissue on the inside and
you can see what this black arrow is
we're getting secondary growth on the
inside of this is woody tissue in the
cortex is to the left of to the outside
of this now over time those roots will
develop into these perennial roots here
these are dark many cases they're black
roots often people think they're dead
but if you slice those open they're
they're nice and white inside and they
have functional feeder roots so and when
they are healthy they will continue to
to be valuable to the plant now if we
take those printery roots and cut them
open you can see it's almost like
cutting open a tree trunk you a very
woody tissue we've got the vascular
tissue design them in here and this
black area on the outside is what used
to be the cortex so as though that that
secondary tissue grows from the inside
out it cuts off the cortex and that it
essentially dies and it's left off and
becomes this black outside the perennial
roots and then the feeder roots that
occur on both these are very soft
tissues no woody growth in them at all
the roots cycle over time we get an
increase in roots to about the time the
plants fruit they tend to go down over
time probably as a result of disease and
then come back again in the fall and if
we further split that up you can see the
the the green areas here are the you
white structural roots again go down
during fruiting and then if they remain
healthy will turn into the black
perennial roots with the yellow circles
and increase over time again in the fall
as well as the way structured what's
coming back again in the fall now what
are the nematodes do so they get in they
cause these lesions they cause cell
death that caused the collapse which
causes that in a chaotic spot you can
see there are areas here where Demi
toads have moved right through the
cortex they they move through the cells
feeding on the contents those cells die
you can see the phenolic sand the
discoloration that occurs around them
and in those cells over time that leads
to this lesion where you get multiple
cell depth nematodes are probably move
through these cells here and then around
this though that tissue dies and then
seemingly the right attorney moves into
this now in addition to directly
damaging cells in the literature and
we've also seen we get discoloration of
the endodermis is this ring that occurs
around the vascular tissue that this is
where the secondary growth starts
becomes discolored it starts to be again
like it was cut open like the phenolic
seeeeee can we get early secondary
growth so the plants recognize it to
being damaged and they produce perennial
roots or on the least part of that root
system faster now so what are the
nematodes in the in the root system very
few are in the perennial roots that not
surprising these are obligate parasites
they need living tissue on which to feed
those woody roots are tough for them to
get into if they do occur in perennial
roots it's probably in the feeder roots
that are associated with those there
they can be higher a number in the
structural and then very common in the
feeder roots very few are in the soil if
we have decent roots most of those
nematodes are not going to be in
soil at all they're going to be in the
structure roots are the feeder roots so
that tells us what kind of roots we
should be taking it for doing sampling
to determine if we have nematodes in the
field and now when do we sample how that
again I mentioned these are obligate
parasites they need root issue on which
to feed you think about what happens to
the root issue over time it peaks in
late May or so and then starts to
decline the nematode populations do the
same thing they mirror roots as the
roots are declining and dying the
nematodes either population crashes or
they move off into the soil and become
tougher to to get back out so that the
peaks are just before harvest so that
tells us not only where do we need to
sample the feeder roots in the structure
rules but when late May so ransacked
onia this is the one the organism that
causes black gujrat gets into the cortex
digest that tissue you can see the
manila lloyd cells here in the
in the cortex these are these are the
this is the organism that causes the
actual rot so where where does this
occur primarily in the in the perennial
roots the Nets left cortex i believe so
if we look at this and either in the
spring or again after harvest late june
or so in the spring most of the rise
like Tony that we isolated and we took a
tire root systems and cut them up into
little two millimeter root sections and
plated these all out and counted the
percent infection more than half of the
perennial roots were infected with
rhizoctonia for Gary initially very
little in the structural roots feeder
roots or even in what seemed to be
lesion nematode areas now I ask those
plants go through harvest they're
stressed the Incan level of infection at
Prairie roots goes very high as do the
level of infection where lesion
nematodes are present so we wanted to
look at what's going on here we actually
did some experiments where we did split
roots we took a straw took strawberry
crowns and split the root system in two
so that we had half the root system in
part one half in the second pot and then
inoculated either with both pathogens
and in different pots both in the same
pot here or only the nematodes or only
the fungus
so just give you a visual roots on
either side either had the pathogens
together or separately now what happened
for disease where we had the most
disease was where we had both pathogens
in the same pot when both pathogens were
present at the same level but in
different sides of the root system we
did not have as much disease and it was
actually the same as if we had only one
or the other so it seems as though it is
not a systemic effect but a localized
effect so what happens here I believe
that the rhizoctonia for Gary seems to
be resident on strawberry roots we've
done a lot of sampling and a lot of
strawberries over many years it's very
common on the root system doesn't always
close disease so we can find plants that
are healthy they will have rhizoctonia
on them mostly on the surface primarily
again on the perennial roots but not
necessarily causing disease when we see
secondary growth starting in the cortex
dying we get increased rhizoctonia
infection when we see nematode lesions
we get increased rhizoctonia infection
and I think the same is true with
environmental stress it's been a lot of
cases where environmental stress
increases blackroot run so again good
stress problems with the roots so what
are the lesion nematodes doing they
cause this root damage directly by their
feeding that results in wounded tissue
there's probably more susceptible to the
riot act onia it also results in roots
producing early secondary growth so we
have areas limited areas in the root
system where the secondary growth occurs
those those parts of the cortex are
being cut off and within there soon
essing and I think that's where the
rhizoctonia moves in first the areas of
the route that have these dis dying
cortex that's the start and it moves
from there into the what would otherwise
be healthy
so lesion nematodes how common are these
we actually did a survey in Connecticut
and a few years ago put this out
twenty-five percent of the growers
thought that they had damaging
populations of lesion nematodes of that
most of those either fumigated used a
matte aside like Nemec you're afeared
and which was labeled at the time or
sometimes did both so the other 75%
either didn't think they had a problem
or were unaware that they had a problem
or said what's a lesion nematode now
lesion nematodes we might actually went
out and surveyed those fields after we
did this in the analysis of asking the
growers you found them in 31 of the 41
fields we looked at for the growers that
had no problems three of those fumigated
with methyl bromide in or and or teal
own so surprised that they they actually
thought they had damaging problems may
be had in the past but for those fields
three of the fields didn't have any
nematodes at all the growers that were
aware of the problem and others that
were even unaware three other word
thought they had problems in eight that
were unaware that didn't manage all had
damaging lesion nematode populations so
they're much more common than people
realized they didn't recognize the
problem i will begin not surprising
because there are no obvious symptoms
other than lesions which can be tough to
see now one of the things we found in
our surveys is the people who rotated
often with small grains this did not
affect the lesion amitha populations
actually made it some cases probably
worse so what are the impacts of
nematodes we had done some work looking
at what nematodes do to reduce yields
and found that if we adapted a model
developed a Cornell by demory and
reichenberg if there are no nematodes
this is 98 numbers there was a profit of
nearly eight thousand dollars per acre
over four years when we start getting up
into damaging levels which would be
somewhere where we consider about a
hundred nematodes for grammar root is
damaging you can see we got a really
get lost in profitability and we start
getting above damaging levels we
actually had a predicta loss over four
years so this is not something that
anybody wants to deal with so how do we
manage black root rot in the past it had
been done with fumigation broad-spectrum
fumigants melfa bromide or lacks things
like that again that becomes is becoming
more difficult or impossible to do
you'll see a lot a lot of times in
recommendations to use rotation but the
question is with what and for how long
sanitation planting clean crowns we did
some work with fertilizers and ammonia
was better than nitrate fertilizers but
give us about ten percent reduction and
then control of lesion nematodes
we also try to do some work with
fungicides seeing if we could use a dip
or drench again rhizoctonia for gary is
pretty common it can even be found in
healthy crowns from nurseries so we
thought if we could break that
association that would help did a bunch
look at a number of different fungicides
and then isolated from the root system
we also evaluated on on auger plates to
see if we saw inhibition in media
department we found the sum head
activity some in vitro meaning in the
plates some on the plants but at this
point this is work that more work needs
to be done to find out what we might be
able to use it be more effective and
some of the newer fungicides we need to
test again I'm sure rich will talk a
little more about this but we've been
working on resistance or tolerance to
black root rot that's one possibility
and there are some varieties that seem
to be more affected than others and
again I think he will speak to this a
little bit finally a cover crop so you
know what do we grow and for how long we
look here this is a graph of
reproductive factor final population
over the initial so it's essentially an
increase how much does it multiplied
over time hairy vetch increases by seven
times so if we start off with a hundred
nematodes probably end up with 700 over
one season mustard it actually increases
rapeseed two and a half times start
getting down into a sorghum Sudan graphs
like Troodon eight and down into
ryegrass we get less of an increase now
not only do we have to just grow these
plants but if you can grow them is
agreement or and incorporate and some of
these plants produce chemicals which can
be toxic to them at those a little
pathak if you will so hairy vetch
obviously doesn't have these properties
the properties is a great host for for
lesion nematodes as is alfalfa some of
the grains but when you start getting
down to the Sioux Texas agro Sudan grass
the rapeseed rye grass and mustard you
can see that the populations are not as
high so you get a bio fumigation or
allelopathically
now in addition we've been working on
there's a Canadian forged pearl millet
we get a we did some work here at the
valley laboratory looking at buckwheat
dwarf Essex brassica which is one that
was a high glucosinolate used for bio
fumigation velvet bean was used down
south and then circle sudan grass and
again this canadian forged pearl millet
and what we found was that the sudan
grass and the and the millet actually
had the best efficacy for green manures
much better even than the dwarf essex
brassica which supposedly is a bio
fumigant but unfortunately it's also a
host of the nematode so that it can
increase it in the root system and then
when you chop it down and turn it under
and you're trying to knock down a
population you just increased so
that I think I will stop and a Kathy do
we have any time for questions yes we
have time for a couple rich is asking
Jim that you would explain a nasty
mostest group to the to the folks okay
well Ryback Tony ax has these different
anastomosis groups these are anastomosis
is fusion so these are these are wide
groups that are that are very similar so
that essentially what the rhizoctonia
does is it recognizes other isolates as
itself and it will will fuse hyphy and
exchange genetic information so if if
you have very similar isolates they are
in the same anastomosis group these
hyphy fuse if they are different enough
that they no longer recognize each other
they're in a different anastomosis group
so that's one way of saying related
strains
ok other other questions for Jim
okay when I use the term radish is that
oil seed radish yes we have been doing
some work with oil seed radish that's we
doing this in micro plots that's in
under way and I can't really speak as to
how well that's working yet
other questions
thanks Jim and you can think about
questions for Jim he'll be back with us
at the end of the program our next
speaker is dr. Richard cowles rich
obtained his degrees in entomology from
Cornell and Michigan State University
after completion of his doctoral degree
he worked for four years as statewide
extension and researched turf and
ornamental specialist at the University
of California Riverside since 1994 rich
has spent a research entomologist at the
Connecticut agricultural experiment
station and is also stationed at the
valley laboratory in Windsor his areas
of study include managing pyrethroid
resistance use of systemic insecticides
integrated pest management and breeding
strawberries for resistance to black
root rot and black vine weevils rich
okay I'm here let me switch to your
presentation
oh good afternoon everybody let's see I
just need to do a little adjustment here
first
can everybody hear me all right
all right there we go excellent a little
bit of an overview for my presentation
now go over the life cycle for root
weevils go over some field observations
for how these root weevils damage
strawberry plantings and I'll go into
some practical approaches to manage root
weevils and strawberries we have a
number of species of importance
throughout the United States of which
black vile evil is present across the
country along with some of the smaller
rule evil species the smaller the
strawberry root weevil and rough
strawberry rootweaver are found
throughout the country to black vile
evil is about half an inch long in body
length that's a black vine weevil
whereas the strawberry root weevil
excuse me strawberry Louisville and
rough strawberry root weevil are about
half that size the leaf evil is a
brilliant green color and unlike the oh
dear Inca species which are the black
violin these other strawberry and rough
fruit strawberry root weevil the leaf
weevil which is bright green reproduces
sexually then in the Pacific Northwest
there may also be other root weevils
which thankfully we don't have in New
England such as a clay colored weevil
the life cycle of black vile evil if you
were to go out right now probably
anywhere in the country you'd find
overwintering pupae and also
overwintering adults blank vile evil and
all of the root weevils pretty much are
long-lived and the adults can live for
more than one year this is of great
concern because sometimes those weevils
that are overwintering as adults may
start feeding and laying eggs far ahead
of the generation that emerges during
the summer but you should have mostly
overwintering pupae and when the soil
temperatures these are the pupae here
let's see okay when the soil
temperatures reach about 55 degrees
Fahrenheit that triggers development of
the overwintering excuse me the larvae
are over went right over here when the
soil temperatures reach about 55 degrees
Fahrenheit that triggers them to develop
to the intermediate stage to the pupae
where they complete development an
emergent about the time that there are
strawberries starting to ripen in the
field the adults feed extensively on the
edges of the leaves for about three to
four weeks at which time they are able
then to start laying eggs eggs are
initially white within a few days they
develop to this a yellowish-brown color
which indicates that there at developing
properly
this feeding along the edges of the
strawberry leaves is especially
important for it's important for a
number of reasons one of which is that
it provides a very excellent way for you
to go out and monitor in your fields to
determine where you have black bile evil
infestations or any of the other root
weevils will cause the same sort of leaf
notching the other thing of concerned
with with the feeding activity is that
where you have a lot of feeding that
implies that the weevils will be able to
convert that foliage into eggs and if
you look at this particular field in
this area right here we had fixed set
irrigation and when the grower went
through and renovated by mowing off the
foliage in that particular field that
was at the time when the weevils were
just about ready to start laying eggs so
you can imagine the season before they
mowed the foliage they could not mow
where there was this irrigation because
of the risers they couldn't take the
mower over it and the weevils from the
entire field were then concentrated
right where the irrigation pipe was they
continued feeding started laying their
eggs where the foliage was still present
in the field and then they moved outward
from that site so in looking across the
field I could see in the fall these rows
of strawberries where the pipes were
turning red and there was less damage
but if there was a very strong gradient
from that that particular row and across
the field and then the next irrigation
pipe would look just the same SS so
where you have extremely tasty foliage
available to the adults that's where
they will be feeding and that's where
they will be laying eggs and then
consequently that's where root damage
will be occurring
the
leave ma Qing within the field is a very
useful measure what we did with surveys
is that we went throughout Connecticut
and we took samples of 100 leaves in
every strawberry field that we could
find pretty much we took the hundred
leaf sample at random and then we sat
down and we counted the percentage of
those leaves that had any signs of
notching which presumably would be from
rue e-ville adult feeding and the
numbers of fields that had a certain
percent of leaf notching then form this
histogram so we had a large number of
fields with fifty percent or less
notching and a few fields that were very
severely affected these are ones in
which the growers would have seen
extreme damage although there was only
one field out of the total of something
like forty two fields or so
that head there was only one filled out
of the 18 in this histogram that had no
signs of any leaf notching and so it
tells me that black vile evil
infestations through fields in
Connecticut are widespread practically
every field of strawberries will have
some root weevil activity it's extremely
rare to find any field that has no root
weevils there are only about a quarter
of the fields that have infestations
have enough to require doing some sort
of management
and in doing our surveys we found that
there were considerable variety varietal
differences so certain varieties such as
all star or Annapolis would be looking
pretty good and yet laboring varieties
such as Kent or honeoye would be
destroyed by black vine weevil
this led to rather an intensive a
project in comparing commercial
strawberry varieties to see on whether
there were genetic whether there was
genetic variation that would allow us
then allow growers to to plant varieties
that had some level of resistant to
resistance to root weevils one of the
methods that I used was to take leaf
discs from different varieties of
strawberries there's just punched out
with the court bore place them in a
petri dish with weevil and then allow
the weevils to feed overnight and some
of the things that contribute to
variation in the palatability of
strawberries to black vine weevil are
the degree of how many leaf hairs they
have and there are other features of the
strawberry leaves too however there are
quite major differences among strawberry
varieties in their palate ability to
like vile evil and this can be an
important thing to use for finding
resistance another aspect that I looked
at was to see whether the root systems
for the strawberry varieties differed in
how well they would support black vine
weevil larval development and of the 21
cultivars that I looked at there were no
there was no variation the larvae
developed equivalently on all 21
cultivars so it's really the foliage and
on differences that are leading to
variations that we see in the field and
damage that's not to say that route
characteristics aren't important though
related to survival of the strawberry
plants and I think the way to look at
this is that there are very likely
interactions with root pathogens so if
we have a cultivars that are susceptible
to black root rot and have as a
consequent consequence of root rot very
few roots
functional roots those are varieties
then that cannot tolerate additional
root weevil feeding on those root system
systems the plants simply then collapse
so if we wish to have a program in which
we're using plant resistance we need to
have a breeding program in which we
jointly improve root disease and root
weevil tolerance the idea here being
that if we can have a strawberry plant
that grows really extensive root systems
that they'll be able to tolerate both
black root rot and black vile evil or
other root weevil level feeding without
compromising the ability of the plant to
obtain sufficient water nutrients and
and then be able to provide a good crop
so black root rot is important because
even though weevil feeding doesn't
increase black root rot incidents black
root rot will remove the amount of root
tissue that's functions and it increases
the injurious pneus of additional root
loss
now both Gemini did squealing trials
with commercial varieties of of
strawberries to see what their what the
variation was amongst them for a
susceptibility to root rocks into root
weevils and I was able to determine that
the leaf hair and nitrogen
characteristics would affect feeding and
there was some other variety and some
other factors involved too and the idea
behind my breeding program has been to
hybridize the superior varieties that
would have both some tolerance of black
vile evil and some tolerance to root
rots to permit directional selection to
improve the very the favorable traits
you can think about this in terms of
animal breeding where we had you know
ancestrally some sort of something like
a wolf and selective breeding for a
larger size animal would lead to the
Great Dane and selection for a smaller
animal leads to chihuahua but they
started with the same ancestry and we
could do the same sort of process with
selective breeding with strawberries by
simply planting those strawberries in an
environment where there is extreme root
disease presence and then only taking
those survivors that fruit well and
using them as parents for the next
generation using this approach we've
come up with a variety that's shown on
the left I call rubicon that should be
released probably in 2012 it's being
it's named now and it is undergoing
patenting that's from our own breeding
program and there's another variety that
comes from British Columbia from a cross
made in 1994 called stolo that is the
claim is that it is resistant to black
vine weevils and so it will be very
interesting to compare these two new
varieties to see how well they perform
where there's a high
degree of root disease and black file
evils
and for managing root weevils are really
three two or three major approaches I'll
start out with biological control of
which really the only commercialized
tool that's been tested has been the use
of insect pathogenic nematodes I'll
mention predatory ground beetles as we
proceed because there are some other
practices that may impact their
effectiveness in suppressing like very
evil populations insect pathogenic
nematodes there are a number of species
available there are ones that are
principally active in searching out
hosts near the surface of the soil that
would be stunning Yuma copper cap see
and there are other species at arm that
dig deeply in the soil they move through
the soil on a water film on the soil
particles how to wrap dittus species arm
the commercial varieties that are deeper
that dig deeper into the soil
number of advantages in working with
nematodes one of which is that they're
exempt from pesticide regulation because
here multicellular organism they're not
really considered to be pesticides
extremely safe for to the environment
and they don't cause pollution of any
sort and more importantly I think
they're able to seek out their hosts
they move on their own to where the host
is in the soil and they're also able to
multiply in the host so you could have
permanent establishment of these insect
pathogenic nematodes in the soil that
then would lead to a suppression of the
weevil populations over a long period of
time multiple years
have an image of an infective juvenile
stage insect pathogenic nematode it's
only about half a millimeter long and
that's the stage of nematode that would
be purchased from a commercial provider
those are applied almost as you would
apply a an insecticide to the field
irrigated in to incorporate the
nematodes and allow them to then move
through the soil on under their own
power they seek out the host and when
they infect the host this is a compu
block here they will go through a few
generations of development within the
host and then will exit the host in
extremely large numbers those in fact
that next cycle if infective juvenile
nematodes can then go through the soil
and cause additional cycles of infection
one of the important things about these
nematodes that you need to understand is
that they have mutualistic bacteria that
live within their guts when the
nematodes infect a soil-dwelling insect
one of the first things they do is that
they release these bacteria into the
kemah seal or the body cavity of that
insect and then the bacteria multiply
within the insect's body and what we
have here is a petri dish in which there
were the mutualistic bacteria placed on
the agar plate and it's showing that the
that there is a zone of inhibition
meaning that those bacteria are
producing antibiotics that protect
inside the insect protect it from being
colonized by fungi or anything else that
might compete with the ability of that
the nematodes to complete development
these bacteria can have distinctive
colors so when we look at and a black
vine weevil larvae that have been
infected by insect pathogenic nematodes
they'll take on the color of the
bacteria the bacterial mutualistic
mutualists that are found with the
nematodes the black final evil on the
right was infected with the steiner Numa
species the one in the center was
infected with a header AB dieded
nematode which will would cause the
larvae to turn a reddish or or brown
color and the larvae on the right is a
healthy black file evil
I've done field trials with insect
pathogenic no toads and this is showing
the results it's a an assessment in the
fall of how many larvae there were in a
sample of two plants and the dates that
are given on the x-axis are the dates of
application for the insect pathogenic
nematodes so in early May application
when we came back in October and checked
we had a very low number of larvae
around those root systems as we progress
through field season 2 jun and then to
august the percent reduction of the
larvae around the root system compared
to the untreated check was insignificant
the explanation I have for this these
dynamics are as follows that when we do
an early May application of naruto's
this sequence significance of this arrow
here is application of nematodes in the
tiding those overwintered larvae and
perhaps the pupae that are present in
the soil might be infected to the degree
of thirty to forty percent of the
population that doesn't do a whole lot
for reducing the black vine weevil
population however what it does do is
allow the nematodes to develop to the
point where there will be infective
juvenile nematodes present in the soil
at great note large numbers when the
next generation of eggs of the weevils
would be hatching and so there'd be
ninety percent or greater infection of
that population of weevil larvae in
august or September some guidelines for
using insect pathogenic nematodes first
you should make sure that the soil is
moist if you do apply nematodes apply
them with any kind of liquid application
of spray equipment i would suggest
though because nematodes are very
expensive to use a boom sprayer probably
banned the nematodes onto the onto the
row as narrow a band as possible do not
use a piston pump because that shares
the nematodes and will kill them and
then you can even apply irrigation while
spraying the neva toads to provide an
opportunity to move the limit oats
immediately into the soil where they be
protected from sunlight one of the great
challenges is people trying to apply
these nematodes on a sunny day nematodes
will only survive for a couple minutes
in in the sunlight typical guidelines
are to apply about 1 billion or treated
acre now of course if you're banding
them on that means it might only
be treating essentially half or
one-third of the total area of the field
so that means that you would only need
to buy proportionately that much many
fewer nematodes to treat a field overall
the results from various field trials
and around the world has suggested that
a fall application could even be more
effective than a spring application
timing but in in both instances soil
temperature needs to be greater than 60
degrees and generally speaking the warm
of the soil the better these nematodes
will perform not only will the nemah
toads be able to move through the soil
faster at higher soil temperatures but
the bacteria that are associated with
the nematodes will multiply in the
infected hosts much faster with warmer
temperatures and it's the multiplication
of those bacteria that actually kill the
insect host we've done field sampling
throughout Connecticut and looking in
growers fields for the presence of
insect pathogenic nematodes and one of
those surprises for me was to compare
fields in which nematodes had never been
applied in which there were eight fields
where we found insect pathogenic
nematodes and then 39 fields that had
none and compare that to fields where we
had purposefully applied commercially
the elbow nematodes and about six fields
out of a door or three-quarters of the
fields we were able to recover insect
pathogenic nematodes probably one of the
more important messages here is that
lincec pathogenic nematodes are found in
our soils and if they're given an
opportunity to infect root weevils they
do and that can be an important way to
suppress weevil populations generally
speaking
application of commercially available
insect pathogenic nematodes has been
kind of so-so in terms of suppression of
weevil populations and I think that
there are a number of problems one of
which is that the commercially available
nematodes may be of questionable quality
compared to those populations that we
find naturalized in our soils so
basically they're great if they're
already there but because of the
requirements for warm soils and there's
really a great degree of interference if
there is a significant clay content in
the soil there are very specific
conditions under which these nematodes
can work well to suppress root weevils
and generally speaking there they've
only been mediocre
if we
move on to chemical control they're
basically two strategies if you remember
in the introduction for this talking I
told you that blankfein we will we volts
will feed for about three to four weeks
before they are able to start laying
eggs this has been considered in the
past to be a great window of opportunity
in which we might be able to kill the
adults and interrupt the life cycle
before they have any opportunity to
start laying eggs and the other approach
would be to kill the love larvae while
they are feeding on the root systems
interestingly for strawberries the
strategy for several decades has been to
kill the adults whereas when you look at
other crop systems such as nursery crops
it's pretty well recognized that
targeting the larvae has been much more
successful in managing root weevils one
of the reasons why this might be the
case is when you think about black v
weevil the plants the other plants on
which they feed her some notoriously
poisonous plants such as taxes on the
left or rhododendron on the right and so
black vinyl evil are adapted to feed on
many toxic plants and this suggests that
they have a really well developed suite
of detoxification enzymes that may
predispose them to be able to detoxify
various insecticides that we're using to
try to kill them
I tried an approach of targeting the
larvae this past year in a field trial
and I compared it with the standard
approach of applying brigade now for
those growers in Canada the equivalent
would be to target the adults with
matador which is lambda sigh hey
Lutheran brigade is bifenthrin and by
fenton and landis a halo throne which is
the active ingredient of Matador are
very similar in their properties they're
broad-spectrum pyrethroids so this is a
comparison of
treatments that are targeting the larvae
actually adults or larvae that's with a
new insecticide called coragem targeting
the larvae only
with platinum or targeting just the
adults with brigade and what's
intriguing to me is that oops is that
the numbers of larvae for those
treatments that were targeting the
larvae were reduced by about half
compared to the untreated check whereas
for the the treatment with brigade which
was targeting the adults of the number
of larvae were no different than the
untreated jacks this was reflected in
the appearance of the strawberry plants
in the field too and what I'd like to
point out to you is this patch of red
foliage that was the bifenthrin treated
plot and that's when I look at red
foliage at the end of the season that's
a good indication of damage to the root
system and the plan severe plant stress
and so it really suggests to me that the
approach that we've been taking for many
years in trying to target the adult
weevils for control and strawberry
fields is really rather misguided one of
the reasons why we might see an extreme
amount of damage where we've applied
bifenthrin or even a or matador
targeting the adults is that that would
have tremendous consequences also in
killing predator editors of various
sorts of which the most important would
be predatory ground beetles here we have
the adult and the adult and the larva
both of which are really ferocious
predators of black vine weevil
just an idea of the kind of dynamics
that might be taking place are shown
with some work that i did with
field-grown nurseries in Connecticut and
what I'd like to do is compare the
intensively managed field that's a
column on the left and the ratio of the
Predators which are the crabbits to the
black vine weevils in that nursery
situation the net was sprayed
intensively with pyrethroids
insecticides and it had a rather
unfortunate effect of killing off the
good guys and allowing the bad guys the
black vine weevils to persist whereas a
field where the grower didn't even know
that they had black vine weevils they
didn't spray at home and the poor black
vine weevils in this field are subjected
to about a 300 to 1 ratio of predators
to themselves so it suggests to me that
targeting the adults of black vinyl
evils might be really misplaced there
are cultural practices that could also
be useful one of which has been tested
in in Canada and the Ontario omelet see
Ontario Ministry of Agriculture Food and
well I can't remember the entire acronym
but the this was published in 2006 by
tolman at all what they're using is a
plastic sheet with a few little supports
and that's a place so that the bottom
edge is in the soil so if you have an
old strawberry field it's heavily
infested with weevils on one side and
planting young planting on the other
side you'd be able to stop the weevils
from wandering straight from one field
to the other and this this barrier has
oops sorry the barrier has right at the
edge a pitfall trap so weevils that are
crawling along the edge of the barrier
okay they'll simply walk along the edge
of the barrier and then when they come
to the end they fall into the pitfall
trap and when different types of
barriers were compared the sheet barrier
was found to catch a lot of the weevils
whereas a different type of barrier was
not but from a practical point of view
one of the things that we see commonly
with especially with them pick your own
type operations is that there's really
limited space for planting strawberries
when growers are putting in fields of
strawberries right next to old plantings
that are heavily infested with weevils
and when the grower is powe under those
old plants the weevils will simply go to
where there's good vegetation and so
that means that they immediately invade
the new planting and you don't realize
this until next year when you have a
severe infestation in the new planting
so the idea is to put in a a barrier
that would be the plastic plastic sheet
that separates the two fields and when
you plow under the old plants have that
barrier in place already and have a
collection pale right at the end of the
barrier to pick up those adult weevils
in summary some of the things that you
can do for root weevil management is to
monitor your planting to determine
whether you have a problem the easiest
thing is to check to see whether you
have stressed plants that have the red
leaves turning in the phone
look for patches in your fields where
the leaves turn red ahead of the plants
in the rest of the field and then that
could be caused by any number of things
root weevils white grubs root diseases
Nana toads so then you have to dig up
some plants and take a look to see
whether the roots are diseased or
whether you have larvae associated with
those damaged plants when the other tool
it's very useful for monitoring is to
look for leaf notching and that you
would do right at the end of harvest
before you renovate and take a hundred
leaf sample and count the number of
leaves that have notches in them if you
have more than fifty percent of the
leaves not by weevils that signifies
that you have a high population that
needs to be managed I would suggest only
considering insect pathogenic nematodes
where where conditions permit basically
sandy soil and warm soil temperatures at
the time of application of the nematodes
consider planting tolerant varieties of
strawberries tolerant to both black root
rot and to black by weevil and in
interesting an important consideration
is to limit the nitrogen application
nitrogen excessive nitrogen conditions
lead to much greater fecundity of the
adult weevils they're able to convert
the foliage in two eggs much more
efficiently and so if you use excessive
leave nitrogen that could lead to
outbreaks of these weevils now of the
insecticides that I tested in the field
only one of which is registered at this
time for control of black by weevil and
that's platinum that's the active
ingredient is is thiamethoxam and I feel
that that's based upon both my work and
work from the Pacific Northwest that
that would be a good strategy i think
that the corojum product also should be
considered for registration for
management of Wi-Fi louisville on other
root weevils it has extremely low
mammalian toxicity and so it would be a
really good tool for us to consider and
then lastly use exclusion barriers to
prevent weevils from moving from
currently invested fields to newly
planted fields that's my presentation so
I I think I'll open it up to questions
or turn it over to Kathy questions for
rich or Jim
while we're waiting for those I'm going
to switch to the end screen and I want
to thank you again for participating in
the Nazca winter webinar series and
encourage you to go to the website where
we have a short five question survey to
help us get a feel for how well you
enjoy the series and what sorts of
topics you would like to have in the
next round
okay Kevin schooley has a question for
rich how would you handle or manage
fields that are being removed
rich
you
rich if you lost your audio
Oh
you
okay sorry about that
couldn't hear anything because it was
echoing so badly in my ears I turned by
my headset off except for the microphone
yeah related to managing fields that are
being removed there are a couple
problems here one is one of which is
that you may have really extreme number
of root weevils in that field there's no
practical way to kill off the adults
with insecticides growers have tried
using these pyrethroids right at the
time that they finish harvest now but
that hasn't seemed to really do a
tremendous amount of good so really the
exclusion barrier to protect nearby
nearby fields is one of the best ideas
to come along in quite a while
there's a question from Gary post he's
wondering if Corrigan is more effective
than imidacloprid ah great question
couraging is a different class of
insecticides I think a better question
might be comparing platinum with
imidacloprid platinum and imidacloprid
are in the same class and I've always
seemed very mediocre results of
imidacloprid for targeting black vine
weevil if that bear got into quite a bit
of trouble when they were trying to
market use of imidacloprid for black
vine weevil control in a special
strawberry production system in England
where they grew strawberries in pretty
much like containers and they'd set them
into a cooler and then they bring them
out into a greenhouse to force the
flowering and fruit development and
corset tried to use imidacloprid for a
black vine weevil control in that system
found that they it didn't work well at
all and they ended up with worse
outbreaks they switched over to using
instinct pathogenic nematodes the
thiamethoxam active ingredient in
platinum seems to be a little bit more
effective against these root weevils and
so I think it has good promise there and
then corrigan i think is probably
equivalent to the thiamethoxam or
platinum for control of root weevils
currently though it is not registered
yet for control of root weevil larvae
rather it's registration and
strawberries that is fork origin is for
targeting pests such as lief rollers or
other caterpillars which is kind of
strange because there I've never seen
them to be important pests in strawberry
fields at least having coragem
registered in any way on strawberries
means that it ought to be a small step
to take so
obtained a label amendment that would
allow it to be used for control of black
5 evil 2 i've worked with that active
ingredient a cell aprem for targeting
white grubs and it's spectacular against
white grubs and so I think that there
might be a good fit for targeting both
white grubs and root weevils in
strawberries with that new insecticide
I think on that far yet I don't have to
call up the company and ask if they'd be
interested are there any other questions
for either gym or rich
well thank you everyone for
participating and again I would ask if
you would please just take five minutes
go to the exit survey and fill it out
for us we would be greatly appreciative
have a wonderful strawberry season and
we hope you'll join us for the next
webinar series thanks